e aí a questionar tudo bom você e eu
acabei pagando pra cá eu não gostava do
meu cabelo grande e eu posso ser quem eu
quiser eu posso ser go passo presente o
perigo eo carro só sei lá o chico sesi
mas a minha mãe solteira
enfim hoje é dia das crianças mas olha
só que beleza hein posso dizer pra vocês
que não sou um rapaz muito velho tem um
recente 18 anos quem você está bem mas
eu senti saudade pra [ __ ] muito na
infância eu curti muito ruim eu não
gosto de uma coisa não era criança
quando ia brincar na onda me sujar vital
e minha mãe falava assim média gostar
dessa lama que tudo é mais criança não
ficava [ __ ] eles vão sair não vou falar
mas deixei pra festa da galera também
fala o meu deus uma criança dessa carne
pra festa ou amanhã eu sou criança eu
não sou não dá pra uma hora senhor eu
não sei mas é um show de mais 100
crianças brincam comigo que eu queria eu
fazia o que eu queria passar uma tarde
toda assistindo televisão tinha empatar
senão assistir tanto televisão para que
eu tenho orgulho de dizer pra vocês que
eu sou uma das únicas pessoas na terra
que sabe cantar a música inteira de um
maluco no pedaço até mexer no computador
e no facebook tal eu começo a única a
honda fechou demais não acho que essa
música até navais daquela resgatando o
cara não tem a letra não sabe que a
pessoa está falando a folha se é bom
cantar cabo nem só de coisa boa gente
lembra da infância um momento que era
uma coisa assim ficava brincando com seu
amigo e tal ele falava assim implantar
aqui eu sou 8 o edital não senhor eu sou
louco por você que é o verde não eu vou
cuidar do seu veículo
o cara fala que eu sou o hotel editar
todo dia
todo dia eu sou um pouco e total do
edital quando ficou claro que só pode
querer seu gol com agora bota disso é o
gol quando posso eu louco não dito do
assunto
não eu sou louco eu sou burro eu sou o
teu um bom quanto eu tenho 41 telco é um
pouco mais fez nada demais porque nunca
mais que o time não importa aqui porque
isso faz isca pode queimar tudo não quer
pode ir para o neymar não pára na sua
amizade cara você não pensa nisso não
não cogitamos o que foi explicado de
ouvir o show meu deus agora cada um do
seu rumo à paz quando você cortar esse
aqui parece que era um laço que se rompe
a amizade está acabada a paz perto a
morrer mas não foi pessoalmente fazer
isso não e ali a amizade acabado por
dois minutos porque depois já estava
brincando junto mas é assim mesmo mas
vamos passo as folhas caem tecnologia
avança tv globinho acaba e até hoje eu
nunca usei a honra de um teorema de
pitágoras o meu deus é por isso que
devia ter aproveitado mais a infância
aproveite infância alega a infância dos
outros você quer assistir você é uma
criança aproveitou fãs que você também é
assim você é um adulto foi o aniversário
do menino leva roupa não é brinquedo
porque não dá para brincar com um short
jeans não dá pra brincar com 12 do ben
10 a mãe pode andar bem entende da roupa
dele roupa quem dá é o pai a mãe tem que
entender que você da casa de 45 reais
o bolso e quarenta e cinco reais no
comendo um pedaço direito a essa câmera
aqui ó ó imagem nova câmera que foi
graças à minha parceria com a ong que
importa é uma loja que vende bens lusa
peço importada tudo é uma das coisas
legais lá é o primeiro de uma percepção
do vídeo quando você visita o site ele
sabe que você foi lá através do meu
vídeo e eles me ajudam a comprar uma
coisa mais difícil a essa câmera muito
boa eu roubei só com o dinheiro que eles
me ajudaram e agora
comprar um microfone ou a iluminação
coisas assim então visitei o site para
ajudar a gente a manter o canal é o
primeiro em que está na descrição do
vídeo que você deixe nos comentários o
momento mais traumáticas da infância de
vocês de momento mais além da infância
de vocês eu quero é a história de peixes
você quer receber sempre vídeo desse
canal
clique aqui no escrever e embaixo do
segundo link que eu pedi que vocês
visitarem a loja tem um link que você
baixar o aplicativo do meu canal aqui
fica o google chrome mozilla tanto faz
ele vai ficar e ele vai ficar do lado
assim toda vez que tiver um vídeo novo
vai ter um arzinho a proceder pode
baixar confiável não é vírus já tem
muita gente que baixou e está adorando
que já pode ver meus vídeos por lá nem é
'muito obrigado' deixe esse vídeo até
aqui e é nóis